nos piden simplificar es real a dos
tercios por s kubica todo esto elevado
al cuadrado que multiplica a la raíz
cuadrada de 20 re cuarta s a la quinta
esto se ve amenazante pero si lo hacemos
paso a paso
vas a ver que va a ser fácil tomemos
para empezar esta expresión de aquí
donde estamos elevando al cuadrado un
producto sabemos que para hacer esto
elevamos cada uno de estos términos al
cuadrado y luego hacemos el producto
esto es entonces r elevado a la dos
tercios y eso elevado al cuadrado que
multiplica a s al cubo elevado al
cuadrado ahora veamos este radical es
prácticamente lo mismo pues sacar la
raíz cuadrada de algo es elevar ese algo
a la un medio
así es que esto lo podemos escribir lo
anterior lo multiplicamos por voy a usar
otro color para hacer esto 20 pero en
vez de escribir 20 lo voy a factorizar
con el producto de un cuadro perfecto y
algo más es decir
esto lo podemos escribir como 4 por 5
eso sería este 20 que multiplica a r a
la cuarta por s a la quinta y voy a
hacer lo mismo con ese a la quinta luego
escribir en términos de un cuadrado
perfecto aquí desde la cuarta ya es un
cuadro perfecto la raíz cuadrada de la
cuarta ese re cuadrada así es que sea la
quinta lo voy a escribir como ese a la
cuarta que multiplica a ese que sea la
cuarta por eso es que sea la quinta y
todo esto elevado a la potencia un medio
continuemos simplificando nuestra
expresión si tenemos algo elevado a la
dos tercios y eso elevado al cuadrado lo
que tenemos que hacer es multiplicar los
exponentes entonces este término de aquí
va a ser igual a r elevado a la cuatro
tercios y este ere el a4 tensión lo
puedes ver de dos maneras
puedes verlo como ere a la un tercio la
raíz cúbica de r elevado a la cuarta
potencia o puedes verlo como r elevado a
la cuarta potencia a la cual está
sacando la raíz cúbica esas dos
interpretaciones son válidas para ere
elevado a una potencia fraccionaria como
lo es
tenemos entonces era la potencia cuatro
tercios que multiplica a ese elevado al
cubo elevado al cuadrado entonces que
multiplica a ese a la sexta potencia
ahora podemos elevar cada uno de estos
términos a la potencia un medio así es
que esto multiplicado por déjame
distinguirlo por colores sería 4 elevado
a la potencia un medio quizás ya no va a
necesitar paréntesis que multiplica a 5
elevado a la potencia un medio que
multiplica
r a la cuarta elevada a la potencia un
medio y esto que multiplica se me están
acabando los colores s a la cuarta
elevada a la potencia un medio y
finalmente que multiplica a s
ese elevado a la potencia un medio hay
muchas maneras de hacer esto pero lo
primero que brinca aquí pues así lo
construimos es que hay varios cuadrados
perfectos a los cuales les podemos
extraer raíz cuadrada hagamos eso 4 a
los medio es 2 la raíz cuadrada
principal de 4 eso que multiplica a 5 al
un medio vamos a escribirlo simplemente
como la raíz cuadrada de 5 que
multiplica a r a la cuarta a la un medio
aquí hay dos maneras de verlo este lo
mismo que ere a la 4 por un medio que es
r a la 4 medios o también puedes verlo
como la raíz cuadrada de re cuarta que
es ere cuadrada s a la cuarta elevado a
la un medio es exactamente lo mismo es s
a la cuatro medios que es s cuadrada y
finalmente el último factor de este
producto que es es el a un medio que es
igual a la raíz cuadrada de s así queda
esto entonces y veamos qué más podemos
hacer
aquí tenemos déjame escribir los otros
términos
tenemos r a la cuatro tercios que
multiplica a ese a la sexta por dos por
raíz cuadrada de cinco por ere cuadrada
por s cuadrada y por raíz cuadrada de s
hay varias cosas que podemos hacer aquí
podemos combinar estos términos en ese
primero o no mejor vamos a poner este
término este 2 primero entonces esto es
2 ahora las veces tenemos ese a la sexta
por s cuadrada aquí podemos sumar los
exponentes cuando se nos pide
simplificar hay muchísimas opciones para
esto en este caso vamos a hacer ese a la
sexta por s al cuadrado s a las 6 más 2
o s a la octava y esto por veamos los
términos en r esto es interesante pues
pues la manera de agruparlos va a
depender de lo que consideremos que es
simplificar tenemos el real a cuatro
tercios por r al cuadrado el real a
cuatro tercios por el real cuadrado el
real a cuatro tercios es lo mismo que r
a la 1 más un tercio eso es lo que es
real a cuatro tercios sumando dos de r
cuadrada nos resulta que r la cuatro
tercios por erre cuadrada es igual a r
tres enteros un tercio y esto puede ser
un poco confuso pues aquí estoy sumando
las fracciones y por acá con la s la
dejé como radical en vez de un exponente
fraccionaria podemos jugar con todo esto
pero al final de cuentas son expresiones
válidas que incluimos las eses ya
incluimos las erres nos falta incluir a
raíz de 5 y raíz de ese que podemos
poner como una sola expresión pero no lo
voy a hacer aún las voy a poner por
separado así es que esto por raíz de 5 y
por raíz de ese ahora aquí hay dos cosas
que podemos hacer quizás no nos guste
este exponente fraccionario y lo podemos
separar o podemos juntar raíz de ese con
ese a la octava pues ya sabemos que esto
es lo mismo que ese a la un medio
hagamos las dos si quisiéramos dar una
respuesta con exponentes fraccionarios
esto quedaría como 2 que multiplica ese
a la octava por raíz cuadrada de ese que
es ese algún medio así es que esto sería
ese a la 8 enteros un medio o ese
elevado a la 8.5 también lo podemos
escribir así es ese elevado a la 82 un
medio que es ese a la 8 puntos
y esto que multiplica a ere elevado a la
tres enteros un tercio estamos
combinando notaciones aquí tengo
notación decimal y aquí tengo notación
fraccionaria con números mixtos y eso
por la raíz cuadrada de 5
esta es una simplificación la tengo por
así decirlo en los menos términos
posibles
la otra simplificación si no queremos
estos exponentes fraccionarios que
tenemos aquí esto lo podemos escribir
como lo voy a hacer en un color distinto
esto lo puedes escribir como no
olvidemos que ambas son expresiones
equivalentes esto depende de cómo
interpretas simplificar así es que esto
lo puedo escribir como 2 que multiplica
a ese al octava que multiplica aérea la
tres enteros un tercio que podemos
escribir como r al cubo por el real o un
tercio y el real un tercio es la raíz
cúbica de r así es que por la raíz
cúbica
y luego tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 5 y
la raíz cuadrada de s ambos están
elevados a la potencia un medio así es
que lo podemos escribir en un solo
radical quedando como la raíz cuadrada
de 5 s me gusta más esta del lado
izquierdo para mí esto es realmente
simplificar tenemos las bases expresadas
una sola vez
aquí tenemos estos dos números los
términos en s están aquí los términos en
r están aquí este es un poco más
complicada tenemos una raíz cúbica hemos
separado las heces y las erres yo media
con esta si alguien me dijera oye sal
simplifica esto como a ti te gusta más